Oh down south I saw a brother take a
bite out of a Vietnamese guy once dude
took a huge bite out of his [__] Ambra
meat and everything ripped it right out
the Vietnamese guy was like threatening
with all this karate [__] and everything
that's the way to do it that stops
karate all the time cuz I don't care
what type of karate you got they got no
defense for the fight I'm saying nobody
well whatever [__] that bites
it O'Reilly I call the manger [__] and
you remember that every time you try to
[__] hug somebody and if you got a
little divot in it you know you got a
speed bump and you [__] hug I told
you when you when you joined the Marines
Oh singing in Miami
yeah the first man I think about that's
kind of stuff like if a plane crash I
already know I'm planning to head dude
I'd eat a Vietnamese guy why because
that's easy it's a starter move if you
attack somebody bigger if you eat
somebody bigger in front of other people
it's kind of alarm people but you gotta
eat a small person so stature is
important I think if you gum down a viet
people are gonna be that upset at you
these people are gonna be super upset
what are you talking about somebody's
dad yeah their sacrifice their more
understanding of things dude is this a
character you're playing no but if you
eat a black dude you eat a black lady
and her family's there they're gonna be
pissed so you think it's Vietnamese
person will let you slide I think that
they'd be much more forgiving over a
couple of day period I think your
relatives you don't think so honestly
one thing no I don't think so I
definitely think they'd be super pissed
at you especially modernized ones but
what is interesting is like Vietnam is
one of the few places where Americans
can go back to Vietnam they don't seem
to hold any grudge at all exhibit a
exhibit a man honestly
well Asian people in general are just
much more forgiving and understanding it
seems like yeah I think I mean I don't
have much I think I think that's a giant
generalization it probably is you know I
mean I did a fast for like four days and
then I was at the Best Buy and and I
remember this Vietnamese guy was trying
to help me out and I couldn't even hear
him I was so hungry and I couldn't get a
fast for four days oh yeah we're trying
to prove I don't know I mean I probably
just dealing with some stuff and I was
just trying to find a different way to
handle it you know right and then I
remember this Vietnamese guy and I
remember thinking if everybody turned
the other way for a second I could eat
this young fella you know then his name
was Ben actually over there in Westwood
but and I never thought God it's so
ridiculous well I mean but here's the
thing I'd never thought that before so
you only thought you got to the verge of
cannibalism after just four days yeah
damn how much weight did you lose
I probably lost about four pounds but
pounds I needed to you know but I got
clear man I could eat and I could hear
swear to god y'all could hear somebody
fold a piece of bread from 80 feet away
bro I was so hungry dude I could hear a
[__] skittle hit the cement across
the street a really good man that voice
that you only let out in front of your
friend yeah and that your friends like
that is [__] hilarious we're having a
conversation at the store one that year
like last week so I got fine with 30
pounds of hamster bones you know they
did in my town that is by the man it
just does it right away you've got to
stop what you're doing that conversation
and giggle because final intent people
wouldn't be proud of that happened there
all the time you know saying like they
would have a hunch in it if somebody
comes nothing like oh uh are you from
the wall he's not really welcome text
wait a second yeah I gotta go you know
you get to that point most [__]
people would be embarrassed to say
something like that or would take them
10 minutes
after everybody told their story yeah
just say oh by the way there's a guy man
no we were just talkin yeah we already
go home and you came out with it and I'm
[__] me and Lee with dining the garlic
what's he talking about
ABB's to me what the [__] is he talking
about and that's a busted him man listen
they got him
what if thank god no I'm glad they got
him dude thirty pound bag of hamster one
like I mean that's cuz you there's not
as much meat there's in very little bone
in a hamster but if I am Scott a ham
probably has like a quart like an eighth
of an ounce in his chest plate but you
can't even make a wish on their bones
you know there's nothing in there where
do you get all those hamsters from
that's it well they breed them in our
town I used to work for this group takes
a cell tattooed hamsters and guinea pigs
after uh they tied to him yeah they used
to brand them with concerts and raised
they would say it's tattooed it's to
make people not be as sad about it but
it was a brand of what we're like a heat
mink but for what look what did it say
3:11 Green Day anything like of
different bands or companies now
nobody's toady's acid bath
we used to truck these house enter the
city in [__] vendôme bra because there
wasn't much going much work in our town
did you know you had to get what you can
get in had a man that bred hamsters and
uh then they had to do the dishes and
you know I'm gonna be [__] up the
whole night with this hamster you leave
when you leave Coco when you leave the
place that's when we get you bra you get
it there hey people leaving on ecstasy
pills they're all Molly you leave you
get that [__] hams you get that warm
little peace of God in their hands they
buy it every time
I was on the road and podcast I told the
truth my main effort rate Lee's on the
griddle of this [__] up hang in there
beautiful Devils in a second I love it
cut it short no will do I will do a
periscope with the lights off Black
Sabbath we sold us so for rock and roll
and we'll lock the door and make it
better to see how will it take before
Lee comes that's the window we locked a
thick we lock this this big girl in our
town we like this big girl one time eat
some acid and we locked this big girl
into a room at this party and we go into
every [__] pot some [__] warm
water [__] I poured it on I feel bad
I feel horrible dude I didn't look we
was kids and we're on a sand dude you
can't tell I'm straight like the girls I
just remember probably 16 I know but
here's the thing let's say I was 14 that
way
[Laughter]
she ate a sit with us dude and what
happened was and we kept going in the
room with like these pots of war I don't
know why we had the possible because I
think for a little honour but not like
torture she wasn't in a cage she was
just you know free-range in this room
right I think she was scared to come out
and so one time we went in bro we heard
this loud sound we went in and she she
had ran against one of the walls so hard
and [__] moved the entire wall in
this house to girl about 240 240 pound
beautiful girl to the most beautiful
biggest girl that I've ever known
beautiful girl beautiful hair beautiful
face Lord just large and beautiful but
she [__] God lifted bro and uh yeah
man [__] I just came down a little bit
off that [__] I just had a little
mushroom [__] high I love you I just
started getting into it do you
oh dude I feel I [__] do workout in
general I used to I used to being like
powerlifting and everything dude I used
to be jacked back
the day really I was an animal do you
know his [__] we're on them steam
powder under my mom steroids the whole
steroids for a while when I was young
really yeah you weren't serious
dosterone something yeah you started to
run a stack just to get Jack yeah I was
like a southern stack it was like
testosterone and like Crisco or
something contesting gravy daddy ball
and [__] Franco so yeah I couldn't
use q-tips in my ears because I couldn't
get my really yeah is there pictures
online of this I don't know there might
be [__] find that chin it might be
I'm just doing it just for it just to
try it out or what I mean if you want to
really know when I really think back and
what I was doing
yeah I'd love that I was just how old we
first of all yeah I was let me see
17 or 18 nope it was after that that's
when I got involved in this damn cult
[__] a real cool are you not on set
that's out and Reseda dude what are you
doing huh why are you looking for the
Lord brother what do you think I was
doing same thing you probably were but
you never hung around black people
things happen bro well it looks like
you're in like Africa they're used to
Santa Clarita and you were just trying
to blend in just an adult yeah dude it's
uh rural it gets pretty long enough to
kiss the sweats
you know long enough to put a warp zone
in your spirit I was out there dude
eatin [__] dolphin dandruff doing dope
out there boy playing Color Me Mine with
my own body living out there boy making
pottery out of my dick but I'll tell you
this man what are we talkin about
Oh steroids what steroids pork you
wearing a cult yeah man I'm doing dick
that's the dark arts Robin and I've been
in the dark art it's a dark place is
there bro but I never been in a fire on
La Cienega lasted [__] but yeah I
used to use them at enhancing drugs and
I'll use duh
dude I remember this yeah now I feel bad
about we did it that bigger girl bro but
we didn't do it cuz she was big we just
did it she just wanted him she just got
[__] up and she couldn't get out the
room you know like I got [__] one of
my best friend's got [__] up one time
and he started talking about Asian
people we never even seen any Asians in
our life and he's not in your life
knowing I guess maybe like in a past
life he might have known some Asians you
know and so he start to bring it up
their names Brian no when I mean no one
should have bought him on this mattress
in this house and I'm like [__] dude
you're [__] up bro I'm leavin right so
apparently I'm the kind of red your
friend is worst Chinese net we never
known any no what is he saying
he's just saying like a you remember
[__] like sin like you remember
[__] Sun lambreaux he was a for us we
don't know him dude you know it was
[__] like talking about Dorothy
Dorothy Dorothy you know we didn't know
any Asians Brun I'm like I got a kid
away but we just came from you know they
had over the first wigger I ever met was
from our town bro I think the first wig
ever man this kid named Brian st. Pierre
bro and they put him it was like dude
that was trying to be black yeah he was
a white dude they move from [__] nowhere
bro he [__] just you know he was
raised like kind of like you know who's
like Mowgli you know like you just
[__] spent a little bit of time on
the other side of town you know
and the brothers really got a hold up
and uh it was cool though
cool you know my whole body just sugar I
thought it was
yoga bra that's an idiot but look man
they put him in the [__] middle II
handicapped class broca's they'd never
seen it before they'd never seen it
before they put him in class with kids
with Down syndrome with kids with in
wheelchairs they put him right now right
now they're probably I'm over here leak
I think it was here in a buzz it hit my
god people who started late because we
was looking around the room he's the
walking buzz over there when I was I was
19 Louie cast lead oh yeah I'm at the
Hard Rock Roxy no in Cleveland
it's actually in the birds man haul road
our car casino in Cleveland Northfield
it's called June 3rd through the 5th and
then I'm at punch line in Atlanta
June 9th through to 12th you catch me at
Doug Benson's podcast I'll be on his
podcast there too I think they're taping
that there then I wanted a beach with my
family
we'll be down there and [__] Saint
Joe's uh like I don't know if it's
Alabama or Florida it's gonna be [__]
up I'll be vlogging a little bit of that
I've dropped a vlog on YouTube you can
check it out it's called this past
weekend and I'd be with my family and
then uh that's it if I could just say
crazy I'm so [__] up in July I'll be
[Music]
without the webpage [__] sambar
Blitzen arrow ready you [__] you gonna
sit them mmm like a bullet shot
typically has a wean leaving this
[__] soldier I don't give a [__]
about what you do but for you to drag
your kid down the dark hey what's up
what's going on buddy you all right over
you know right over there you wanna go
out saying it's a man tell me true you
wanna go outside gets a man let me do
some [__] call a shout-out say we'll
wrap this [__] now don't start
let him get electrocuted it's alright we
need somebody gonna let your kids on
this stuff
[Music]
I see don't save me bro is a brother
save me man please you stop already
you got electric lease let's come in a
day early to the test the rides we
didn't know we didn't know we were
getting 30 cents get on the ride ones
and twos leave we don't give a [__]
[__] cannon hit you need help to get
some hair you're not gonna vomit on the
[__] table oh yeah
the cannon hit Lee man wow you know it's
crazy as my sister can't even read but
what does it have to do with us right
now hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy two
options watch one this one or this one